m
[Silence]
We are
continuing in our book
obviously this class centers
around has been our book for the past
few years that we have studied and
researched and followed authored
by
and in this
book the focus and the spirit of the
book book
of is everything that has to do with the
prophet
sallam everything anything having to do
with him or his life or his times or his
what he said and what he did and how he
did things whether it be religious
issues or religious duties or even
things that are not
necessarily or things that are specific
to
him
and a big part of
that is the chapters regarding the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
character the chapters regarding the
appearance how he actually looked and
chapters regarding the Miracles of the
Prophet
Sall he mentions many of the Miracles
of the Prophet sallallahu alaih wasallam
throughout his life there are other
books that were written before and
after which have either the entire book
is dedicated to the Miracles of the
Prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
or a substantial portion of the book is
dedicated to that topic so for instance
has a very extensive collection in a
book
discussing the prophet sallallah
alam's Miracles throughout his
life the name of the book
is it's a very dense very
extensive
likewise in his
book which we are currently taking a
detour into to to read these issues to
read this topic in a more comprehensive
manner he
discusses you know with
with with a bit of summar
ation an
bridged collection of the Prophet
Sall
alam's Miracles likewise we have
after has a huge very extensive
section in his book on
History one of his most famous and
popular and well-known
works and in this after
he mentions the biography of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam he has many
chapters dedicated to all of the
Miracles of the Prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam it's almost an
encyclopedia it's very extensive
obviously his book is completely
dedicated to that topic and even cath is
slightly more
summarized so we decided to take this
more summarized
approach in the interest of
time more summarized approach and read
the chapters
in authored
by regarding
the descriptions of the Prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam the character
of the Prophet sallallahu alaihi wasall
both of which we have completed and now
the or the Miracles performed by the
prophet
[Silence]
m
qu
[Silence]
he begins this chapter obviously with
discussing the qu Quran the Quran is the
greatest of Miracles not just that the
prophet Muhammad Sall alai wasallam was
given but it is the greatest of Miracles
bestowed upon any Prophet or
messenger this is clearly mentioned by
the prophet sallallah alai wasam in a
narration collected by both bukari and
Muslim in which he says that which trans
Ates to there has never been a prophet
sent before me except that he was
given
Miracles that
are the these Miracles are so
compelling that people would believe in
that Prophet because of witnessing these
Miracles or what is meant is that people
should believe they are compelling
enough and enough of an argument to
prove the validity of any of those given
prophets claim to prophethood he said
and the greatest of that which I was
given of
Miracles is the Quran is a revelation
that was sent down to me and so I
am optimistic and hopeful that I will
have the most followers on the day of
resurrection and so this
Quran is the incredible words of
Allah subhanahu
waala which
jel heard from
Allah and this was over the course of
23 years 23 plus
years in different places in different
times on different occasions
jel would be commanded by Allah to come
to the prophet
s and recite to him whatever of the
Quran he was commanded by Allah to
recite to him which was appropriate for
the occasion or time or juncture that
the prophet Sall Al wasallam and his
companions were in or
at this Quran
Allah subhah
waa
[Silence]
subh
for
Allah subhanahu waala
discusses the protection of the
Quran in verse 42 of the
chapter Allah subhanahu waala describes
the Quran saying that which translates
to falsehood approaches it not from
before it nor after it meaning in time
in place in
manner that this book the Quran is a
revelation sent down and
bestowed by one of immense wisdom and
one worthy of all
praise the Quran is not only preserved
by Allah subhanahu waala meaning only
its words its words being preserved on
their own without the meanings of those
words being preserved is not very is
not very beneficial Allah subhanahu
waala sent down the Quran and preserved
its
wording and over
time
mankind usually throughout history the
different nations before us that were
given Divine revelations in books by
Allah subhanahu
waala they
perverted those books over time they
either perverted the actual wording of
the
books or they perverted the meanings of
their books of their respective
Revelations they kept the wording but
they started to play and meddle with the
meanings of those words using different
arguments and different chah hat
to try to pervert the meaning Allah
subhanahu Waal mentions both types of
perversion that occurred to the prior
Revelations of Allah he says subhanahu
waala in two different verses he
says
[Silence]
for
subh
[Silence]
how come
so when we look into the Quran we see
that Allah subhah discusses in
detail the previous Nations that that
came before us he
discusses the types of changes that were
made to the words and Revelations of
Allah the messages of their
prophets the people who were entrusted
the scholars of the previous Nations who
were
entrusted with preserving those meanings
preserving those teachings preserving
the wordings of those of those
Revelations they did not follow through
and live up to that
entrustment and so they changed and
perverted the words of Allah but there
are really two ways to pervert the re
ations of Allah the words of Allah the
first way and both are mentioned in the
Quran the first way is to actually
change the
words themselves add letters take
away letters add words take away words
this is a type of
perversion they're trying to write or
add to the book what is not of it in
order to support or in order to
fulfill whatever agenda they have and we
see this a lot especially in
translations of translations the
Bible for
instance there are more than 40
different or or about 39 38 or 39
different versions of the
Bible and when we say versions of the
Bible we're not talking about changes in
General meanings we're talking about
changes in the Bible these different
bibles are different in the amount of
verses they have the amount of books
they have some of them have 10 less
books 10 more books 13 more books and
then there has there's other there's
there are other groups that have their
own parts of the Bible that they say
this is actually a part of the book and
so
forth and so a lot of words were added
that were not part of the actual words
of Allah subhanahu waala that were not
words of the
revelations very prominent very
clear the other type
is is possibly more
dangerous the second type
of changes that can be made to the book
is arguably more
dangerous and that is that a person that
what they did is they
left the actual wording as it
was but they changed the meaning of the
words in their actions in their worship
and their
teachings right so for
instance the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam tells us of many ways that this
happened for instance in Muslim the
prophet sallai wasallam says
[Silence]
y the prophet Sall alai wasallam tells
us that the
Jews the followers of Moses
Allah subhanahu waala prohibited upon
them the
fat of animals when they eat meat it has
to be just meat no
fat and this is one of the things that
they earned due to their Disobedience to
M Allah subhanahu waala mentions this
in
[Silence]
subhah
waala so Allah subhah waala prohibited
upon them the fat of animals the fat of
of cows the fat of
goats and as for camels that was
prohibited upon them from
before and so what did they
do of course if a person can only have
just meat no fat at
all this takes away a lot of
the a lot of the taste of the meat it's
just RAW Protein the fat is what gives
meat a good taste right you have a
little bit of fat when you fry it or
cook it or whatever that's what gives it
its
taste when it's just lean
meat constantly and they're not allowed
to have that
extra this is something that is a type
of
reprimand because they continue to
disobey most
and Allah subhanahu
waala obligated these things upon them
and prohibited them other things such as
this in order to punish them for their
Disobedience and
so what did they do they didn't change
that in the book they left it as it was
that yes we are not allowed to eat the
fat of
animals what they did is they took the
fat and they melted
it they changed its outward appearance
its
form and then they sold it and they
profited from
it now obviously if Allah prohibits
something on someone everything about it
is prohibited it's prohibited to sell it
it's prohibited to manufacture it
whatever it
is and so they tried to technically work
around it they changed the meaning of
the prohibition of Allah Allah
prohibited upon them what the fat of
animals he prohibited upon them selling
or buying it is just for us
pork the Flesh of swine is Haram it's
not okay for us
to because we can't eat it to take it
and sell it it's not okay for us to
change it outward form and sell it this
is Haram it's money and its profit are
all
Haram and
so they they just changed its outward
appearance playing games and
technicalities right and that is well
the fat is Haram but if we melt it down
then it's not technically fat anymore
now it's whatever something else and
then if we sell that you know I'm not
eating it but let someone else else
benefit from it kind of thing this is a
type of behavior that changes the
spirits and the meaning of the
revelation of Allah subhah wa tala it
perverts the spirits of the prohibition
the spirit of the prohibition is what
the fat of animals is Haram that's it it
needs to be discarded it is not
permissible to consume that's the
spirits of the prohibition
take it and change its appearance and
change what it's technically called
right so for instance it's Haram for
a person to a Muslim to eat swine so we
take it and we cook it a certain way to
where it's called something else now
right and then we sell it as that
something else this is on the entire
process was Haram and so in this manner
playing these kinds of games
another way that Allah mentions in the
Quran is that he prohibited upon them
fishing on the day of the Sabbath on
Saturday it's not permissible for them
to
fish so what did they do they would put
out their
Nets on Friday night Friday
evening and then come back Sunday
morning and collect whatever fish got
caught in the Nets technically we
weren't there fish fing the Nets were
fishing on their own right this kind of
playing games with the spirits and the
wording this means that the words have
no effect on us right and this does
happen in this umah and this is much
more prominent than trying to actually
change the wording of the Quran or
change the words of the Sunnah trying to
say the prophet sallallahu alaih
wasallam said something that he did not
say this is
impossible the scholars will always
catch it it's not something that will
get
by likewise to try to change the wording
of the Quran this is something that has
been attempted failed miserably every
time however trying to change the
meaning of the
words this is something that is more
prominent and far more dangerous why
because we can never purify people's
minds from that poison
again so for instance people will come
upon you know anything in the Quran a
Prohibition in the Quran a command in
the Quran we say yes you know RBA is
Haram but really what
isba right now we start playing games
with semantics and playing games with
words and playing game right until
finally we make whatever we want because
of some technical ity and leave the
wording itself is there but the me
meaning and the spirit of that
prohibition is not being implemented and
not upheld this is a type of perversion
a type of that occurs this Allah
subhah waala has blessed it with a book
that cannot be
changed literally and also its meanings
cannot be changed
and this is an important
point
because if you can
imagine that the Quran that we
read has been on this Earth for about
1,500
years and it's been all over the world
in every
civilization nowhere in the world since
the Inception of the revelation of
Muhammad sallu alai wasallam has the
Quran not been
involved in the world's history since
then many different types of people many
nations many they all entered into Islam
or were affected by Islam or interacted
with this book the
Quran the fact that it has not been
changed it's the same no matter
what the Quran is just a given it's like
it's gravity we know gravity works
it's always there we don't worry about
gravity not working tomorrow right no
it's always there it is a it's it's a
law of our world that the Quran is
preserved by Allah subhah wa
tala but if that preservation was only
for the words and Allah subhah wa taala
did not preserve the meanings of those
words how perverted would the religion
of Islam be by now would be almost
completely
unrecognizable but Allah subhanahu
waala sent with the Quran the Sunnah and
the Sunnah was preserved the Quran was
preserved and anyone who tries and any
group of people or any movement that
seeks to separate between the Quran and
Sunnah has always failed
miserably and continue and will continue
to do so because we cannot dis anguish
and separate between Allah and his
Messenger
s likewise every
meaning of every word of every verse of
the
Quran is known to the Nation of Islam
the Muslims as a whole at any given time
until the Quran is taken back by Allah
subhanahu waala its meaning is preserved
by
Allah and how is it preserved by Allah
by the preservation of the
Sunnah and by the pres by the
preservation of the Integrity of Islamic
scholarship now this doesn't mean that
every single scholar of Islam or every
single person who is knowledgeable in
Islam is of great integrity no but it
means in general as a whole the
scholarship of Islam will always have
integ rity and that Integrity be
uncompromised that the words the
meanings of the words of the Quran of
the Sunnah cannot be
changed they are there the prophet
sallallah alai wasallam tells us in a
narration in a he says that there will
always
be a group of my nation and this group
may be more numerous or less numerous at
different times more more pre prevalent
or less prevalent at different in
different places but there will always
be collectively a group of people banned
amongst my umah that will be clear
obvious accessible upon the
truth of the Sunnah of the Prophet Sall
alai wasam they will not be any will not
be truly
affected by anyone who forsakes them
or attacks them until the end of time
there will always be a group of Muslims
upon the Islam the interpretation the
spirit the meaning the understanding of
the prophet sallallahu alaih wasallam
and his companions so we's taken a lot
of time discussing the Quran because
again this is the
greatest
miracle that any Prophet or messenger
has ever
had
[Silence]
says
and
[Silence]
subh
subh he describes the Quran he says this
Quran has rendered helpless and
incapable the most
eloquent and prolific of
speakers poets writers
authors wind wind
speakers in the most prominent time
of eloquence meaning that Arabic is a
very old language and people speak it
and it takes a
community time to perfect that tool that
they have it's for instance imagine
electricity
right we discovered electricity whatever
as as a as human beings however many
years ago I don't know 150 200 years ago
right did we perfect its
use when we first discovered it no we
had to practice we had to trial and
error right and
competition to where we have for the
most
part harness this this power in a way
that is you know we're very skilled with
it the same thing with
language the Arabic language very old
language but over time as human beings
experiment with this language as
human beings speak this language as they
practice this language as they pass on
each generation passes on its
discoveries to the generation to
follow and the generation that follows
builds upon those discoveries right this
is how human thoughts and this is how
knowledge
works
people will reach or a civilization or a
people will reach a pinnacle a climax a
point where they are most skilled at
that particular
thing the peak of their eloquence of
their perfection of their knowledge of
their efficiency with the Arabic
language was at the time and in those
few Generations in which the prophet s
Alam lived and was sent
right now what happened is after that
the Arabic language its proficiency
started to go down amongst the general
public
why
after
[Silence]
sh
so the scholars pretty much agree
that after the 2 Century after
hij that is when we see in the general
masses the general public of the AR
those who speak
Arabic the proficiency level started to
dwindle started to go down now the
scholars of Islam will always speak
proficiently and always know the meaning
of the Arabic language but we're
speaking about the general public
speaking the pure Arabic language
correctly why did this
happen the reason that this happened is
that when the Muslim empire
spread they went into places where
Arabic was not the native
tongue people from other
nations that spoke other languages began
to become Muslim to accept Islam or
Islam would be in that area and so just
as with any civil ization when you mix
with another civilization there's you
leave an effect on them they leave an
effect on you and that happens not just
in interaction it happens even with
products when you import a product from
another country let's say a fruit that
is not native to your land and you
import it you usually import its name
with it too from the other
people and so this
interaction started to you know other
words other ideas other other ways of
seeing thing or describing things
started to impos into the psyche
of the Arabs and the Muslims and so
the Arabic
language the proficiency of its people
in that
language began
to go
down and so the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam was sent
with the Quran to the Arabs and the
Quran came at the time when the Arabs
were most proficient in the Arabic
language Humanity as a whole has not
ever
perfected or been to that level of
proficiency in the Arabic
language as they were back then since
then it went
down and so Allah subhah
challenged those who
intended that the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam
was fabricating this book from
himself if he could do it then other
people can do it as well that's the that
is the the that is the evidence that
something comes from a human
being no matter how good I am at
something there's always going to be
someone who's better at it and someone
who's better than that's someone who is
better this is the nature of human
beings and
so the challenge was look if you guys
are claiming you you don't accept that
he is telling you this book this Quran
is from Allah subhanahu
waala then you should be able to
manufacture one it as a matter of
fact you should be able to manufacture
one better right because you have the
Quran now as a as a guide as a yard
stick add on to it make it better
impossible and many attempts were made
perhaps we will mention some of them
inshallah
subhah challenged them to this and also
foretold that if all of creation all of
humankind and gen kind were to
collaborate and Aid one another as a
group effort they would never be able to
manufacture not even one chapter of the
Quran which is similar or competing with
its eloquence its wisdom and its
Perfection his
[Silence]
divinity
allar